plus loin avec notre invité au legs
kaupthing bonjour merci d'être en direct
sur france 24 vous êtes historien et
géographe professeur de géopolitique et
spécialiste de l'europe de l'est comment
vous vous expliquer ses succès ukrainien
c'est grâce à la bonne stratégie d'état
major ou ou c'est parce que l'armée
russe a des faiblesses
je crois que c'est c'est les deux
les qualités de l'état-major ukrainien
c'était le grand secret finalement
géostratégique de toutes ces dernières
années et la faiblesse de de l'armée
russe c'était de ne pas avoir pris cela
en compte il faut aussi préciser que
l'aide militaire à l'ukraine
avant les livraisons d'armes et avant
même le
l'offensive russe l'invasion russe
s'était c'est lé conseil militaire
prodigués par les américains à l'heure à
leurs collègues généraux colonels et
autres stratèges ukrainien
bien sûr il va y avoir un effet de
surprise évidente pour les russes on ne
s'attendait pas à une telle contre
offensive un tel succès est-ce que ça
marque un tournant dans le conflit est
ce que ça peut avoir un effet sur le
moral des troupes russes est ce que ça
peut les démobilisés
il ne faut pas que les ukrainiens a créé
crient victoire trop tôt parce que oui
ils ont gagné trois mille mètres carrés
mais c'est une guerre qui commence à
ressembler à peu à celle de 14-18 n'ya
pas les tranchées mais c'est quand même
une guerre de position différente bien
sûr par beaucoup d'aspects à la guerre
de 14 néanmoins c'est une guerre de
positions et on se rappelle que dans les
guerres de position on prend on reprend
c'était comme le fort de douaumont
souvenez-vous de
[Musique]
du films avec gabin on prenait on
reprenait
et on ne sait pas ce qui va se passer
demain et s'il y a une contre offensive
russe
il ya eu autre chose qu'il faut craindre
énormément c'est que si effectivement
c'est une défaite sérieuse de l'armée
russe et si les troupes ukrainienne
continue continue à avancer et bien la
réaction peut être assez terrible
il faut craindre il faut être prêt voire
à des atrocités voir l'utilisation de ma
de d'armes de destruction massive on
peut s'imaginer
des l'utilisation de gaz est aussitôt
d'ailleurs ce sont les ukrainiens qui
sont accusés par le kremlin de les avoir
utilisés donc faut il faut être prêt au
pire également est une déclaration de
guerre de la part de poutine avec ce que
ce que cela susciterait une mobilisation
générale de tous les deux tout les
russes mobilisables
c'est un des c'est un des scénarios du
pire où il faut il faut s'y préparer
et je l'entends préparer
cet unibet c'est une hypothèse
extrêmement importante et pour laquelle
il faut être prêt est ce pour vous
est-ce que c'est des routes sont évoqués
en russie est ce qu'ils les
reconnaissent ou pas
alors
ils reconnaissent il dit il parle de
regroupement il ya un regroupement en
arrière on se réorganise c'est comme ça
que la plupart des journaux les plus
contrôlées par l'état l'expriment
d'autres quand même le laisse je crois
que là comme ça moi est-ce que pravda
vous la connaissez mal ce que gaz y est
quand même laisse entendre qu'il ya eu
défaite vous avez géré j'ai envie de
citer tolstoï dans guerre et paix il ya
le vieux prince
le vieux prince qui le le père du prince
andré vieu brass band qui lit les
journaux de l'époque dont on annonce que
les troupes russes ont quitté austerlitz
après des reliques combat et le prince
comprend que la défaite a été lourde
une dernière question sur en quoi est ce
que ça pourrait fragiliser poutine
puisqu'il commence à y avoir quelques
voix qui critiquent la stratégie
d'ukrainiens il y a visiblement deux
groupes de députés municipaux à saint
pétersbourg qui ont exigé que poutine
quitte le pouvoir bon bien sûr cette
demande n'a aucune chance d'aboutir mais
ça illustre une certaine lassitude chez
les russes concernant cette guerre qui
dure depuis six mois maintenant
je crains qu'il ne faille attendre
beaucoup plus longtemps pour que la
population russe
puisse vraiment d'abord seront dans le
compte de ce qui se passe primo secundo
réagir à ce qui se passe et des tertio
le parlement russe par exemple la douma
ne bouge pas du tout je crains que ces
conseillers municipaux comme beaucoup
d'autres voient d'ailleurs des
intellectuels des universitaires des
milliers d'étudiants qui ont signé des
pétitions m il ya eu quelques milliers
quelques millions de manifestants mais
on a vu que ça n'a absolument rien donné
le parlement la douma ne bouge pas donc
malheureusement il va falloir attendre
avant que qu'une pression ne puisse
réellement s'exercer sur poutine merci
beaucoup aux legs comme cif pour vous